welcome to this video playing Bruce a
meaner boo the mena from Germany which
would translate to she translated
literally is the evil face but this is a
character from a from a German comic
book so it probably refers to that
female character but ok let's see we
have this this crazy gruenfelder with h4
and let's see what is doing see six
years it sets the most solid reply and
then playing Bishop g5 interesting
very quickly played element I'm not
really the expert on the slide so it's
hard for me to judge this move
can hmm it probably strengthen this D
takes e4 idea to gain the pawn but queen
bee three is of course a natural answer
probably is going to play Queen B 6
Jerry hard to say well he really
threatens to take him and yeah maybe I
should just capture yeah difficult I
mean this was really hanging I guess I
need to react to it and now queen bee
three yeah maybe putting some pressure
on be 72 seems fairly logical after
Bishop b4 jam gotcha to do green b6 Mary
Jo couldn't be six I might really just
take it's not done a big problem the
double problem but still something that
i can think i can play on yeah this H
shawn wolfe is really strange at this
type of position it's really not doing
much sometimes you have h5 relief but
only in some some weird cases ok so just
trading you you know i guess i should i
should really do this was in the the
pawn structure yeah might be five cannot
be five if it has some point the the the
simple factors he needs to reply night a
six I think 97's some sort of a double
threat even if you move the rock the
snide c7 and taking on e6 which is bad
enough
and really yeah okay i'm going to do
that simply because i think that the
night on a six is not terribly well
placed and what now maybe Roxy banya at
the moment team of course cannot play he
cannot play night before and need to get
something on the on the C file what I'm
wondering is maybe you can just simply
Castle play Roxy eight and then my
developers my development is not
especially great and damn that's
certainly true
yeah I'm not very developed the night on
a six is not well positioned okay but
what exactly what exactly does it does
it do me does it do me any good I mean
ok I think I if he goes rook c8 I need
to have looks III as reply other than
that i'm giving up the sea far so i
probably need to take him which is not
great but 94 assam is a big problem okay
let's at least make sure that that the
night is not easily coming back into the
game so look see 30 nights III mmm yeah
let's do whoops III don't want to
retreat the night but you can simply
play if everything else fails so like
you can go Bishop d7 and just heck this
night off with a very comfortable
position really you know when I
discussed this discussed lots of time my
mahal action here with 95 okay but let's
hope that I'm not in trouble
I don't think I can be worse here really
now the two bishops but the position is
really really static okay let's just
briefly check pawn takes but it's not
really really useful yeah I will just
turn complete development finally within
three and III Bishop d3 Kingda to
something like that mhm oh that's
interesting going for 96 to see for
maybe
I have my g5 here it's a situation we
cannot move the bishop away yeah then
this should be good really I can either
take it and worsen his pawn structure or
or if he takes this is a huge
accomplishment h takes G and this opens
my rock and leads to a position where I
really have the better structure my
structure is somewhat better anyway but
it's not not meaning much but you must
be must be consciously I mean I may be
threatening to take on e6 this e 6f E
and then F for this might lead to a
position where I completely dominate
sagara Arthur I know the position is not
even equal it's it's now it's it's
pretty clear that i'm somewhat better
and i think at least let's let's see how
to continue d 5 year d 5 is a point that
i can attack Bishop d3 is going to play
my bishop at five d 5 is hanging so
probably he and King lead to
probably 22 yeah this is a possibility
of covering d5 from the side okay maybe
he can play Bishop f5 and then I need to
retreat it yeah okay but it's not the
end of the world it does not change the
fact that I'm a structure slightly
better and that's also after Bishop f5
the possibility to play be four but it's
probably nonsense right before yeah it
is nonsense before rook takes 95 in
scotts checks known that is really bad
even but ok Bishop f5 Bishop b2 is not
not really a problem he can exchange
with nitey form but I just take and then
click on the C file
this position is own name deceptively
equal really what is really more
comfortable i'm curious what the
computer is giving really sometimes the
machine is far too far too conservative
in this kind of position maybe if it's
only giving 0.1 or so for why that's
really too little if i'm given time i'm
doing things like f3 recovering eform
roxy one night a to roxy seven-night to
be four maybe Roxy seven there are
various ideas but black cannot do much
really check you know you can exchange
that that's that's maybe the best way to
do the best way to go but note that I'm
click on the C file now well okay so his
idea is to get at my Jeep on should I
play a form to secure the pole takes
takes Bishop somewhere and for your
problem I must I must keep the corner
giving it away snow option
so the idea is Roxy one ox is seven
maybe maybe you can just play Bishop d7
to c6 block then block like that it's a
bit passive but maybe not bad if we go
special d 7 for example to start this
and attacking g5 I wonder if I should
play a 4f for Bishop c6 you will get the
bishop to e form maybe I'm wrong on
Bishop d7 I better play work g1 and
covering it yeah and now cover it and
then go for a for King III f4 and the
center maybe this is better really and
for bishops is 6 no this is better
Bishop b5 is the possibility also now I
have before this blunder splendas
material ok ok
and yeah I'm not sure how much this is I
mean I have ideas efore King III f4f
ways to to expand him but like ian has
very little active things to do but yeah
this is this is relatively active move
but still I wonder if I take if you
maybe give the check here here here but
I can Roxy five I can go all the way to
deform I guess bhakti fire this is maybe
better than taking after tick I have the
smooth with the idea to play King III
and therefore
so King III is going to go rook c5 maybe
this before I could move an interesting
question I don't really threaten f4
anyway as cm is on the e4 pawn I go here
Bishop rocks but Roxy 5 is really
nothing more I can go 83 ok then King
III years are useful yeah how do I
prepare for probably a special death
from you ok
yeah I think he has defended as well he
can if he go if he manages to play age
six and exchange gyh porn it's very very
little I would still continue of course
I have Brooke c1 Roxy three rugby three
attacking his weakness on b6 and so on
but it's um it's still very little an
important thing is that after i have
played a form i must be aware of the
idea to sacrifice on d4 and then fi of
gaining it getting it back like let's
say h6 takes on h6 King takes and if I
play later f4 rook e8 and something you
can play a 50 K and play first this year
okay is there a point in FF and probably
not
if I play I wonder I wonder about if I
just allow him to take if this maybe cuz
this may be some sort of idea
Kingda for takes on g5 route 35 yeah
rook takes and then f6 yeah this is some
less than nothing okay yeah I probably
to take and now just King deform yeah
probably gaining bit more space maybe
before coming okay so is he going to
play what is he going to do Brooke look
on the second-ranked maybe
hmm shopify go Bishop to c4 they just
playing King back problem
hmm yeah it's um not much going on
really before be 5 mm what is the what's
the best way to post some problems a
promise that he has this counter attack
on f4 maybe maybe this is still the
relatively best way to play rock h4 I
play b5 it moves and then we'll see one
Roxy 7 trying to get if possible both be
pawns the rook h2 now you can try rook h
2 a2 yeah but ok b5 this comes with lots
of tempos once Lucas of the fifth-ranked
yeah it's obviously very little but them
i still think black has more problems to
solve him
maybe be five just be five but this
video's be five then yeah then at least
the bishop end games tend to be critical
lots lots of pawns on light squares not
sure that this is meaning much but it's
um it's one point
ya doing not doing much but ok mr. Luke
on the G for doing something useful
fingers look H Freud play b5 this is the
idea he goes be 55 rocks if I'd
immediately it's not threatening much
but still
ah maybe I'm I can play a for Bishop
takes rook c7 and this combines b7 and
Bishop c4 attacking f7 hmm this could be
an idea let's let's check this before i
give this check tags giving the check on
Roxy 7 and I'm not risking anything with
this or not Bishop c4 and I'm not really
then this is a good idea maybe you
really only know afterwards and now I'm
attacking here and if I manage to take
it then the b6 bonus immediately week as
well and I have Rob Bishop c4 and this
is a bit annoying pressure on f7 Bishop
c4 am
if he goes rogue age 7b five winning
both pawns you know this is black is
under some pressure now
if he attacks here somehow i can take f7
now this is this is now getting shaky
right I think okay if I take should I
take I can also take with the bishop but
then rook age 70 okay patike here and
then Bishop to e6 there's no technical
problem yes I think I don't see one at
least yeah it's still equal material but
yeah I've made enormous progress what
are possible ways to improve if I've and
maybe King c-56 now the King invasion
would be excellent but there's also the
simple question what is he doing against
rook g6 rocky g7 and the possible porn
capture yeah this is this is a move but
look f5 and tending Bishop f7 and this
is a pena
ah I cannot take with the pawn because
he for hangs ah what a shame what a
shame
mmm then that wasn't the best way to
play very likely okay what exactly
should I do I can take of course here
and that's that's not good i guess was
with the right amount of precision um I
was very close to winning this is of
course still good for white but it's not
it's not not an easy win probably at
least I don't have I don't see it there
are often no of course not me I'm just
better here why should i take the draw
and i'm not like enormously behind on
the clock
check threatening mate okay how to do
that
there's no way to play for direct mate
check
50 seconds is not much really check
check Jim were probably check check
wasn't this a draw well now it's not
that black resins who was really
oppressing water out of stone but it was
it was better I mean what can I do I
decline to drawers but in both positions
why does hadn't had something I mean
it's not like I'm playing on time or so
but around TM around GM I'm really
curious where where I just bought this
so this can I overlooked true cash flow
I mean it still preserves an edge I mean
maybe that isn't more it's possible and
yeah he's got this fact this is just a
problem the thing is bad on the aid
check yeah here I guess with precise
play I should I should really win it
what happened to us it was it wrong okay
what is the computer giving him King d8
strangely enough
this is not working Kinji 76 yeah this
is this is similar to the game actually
check ah here can just take be five okay
well i only had didn't have much time
but this is winning as well check so
this is winning all along that's
interesting this is a draw okay Luke b8
is a win hmm not the not ki cannot
really say that I'm understanding this
like this and what now cd8 first I awoke
b6 them okay rupee six yeah I really
couldn't couldn't tell us a little time
but it was certainly a draw right softly
right up to here until you played this I
mean don't don't really understanding
why we can just check and it should be a
draw this was an interesting interesting
endgame queenless middle game however
you want to call it I was losing really
lots of time and get into this got into
this position but relatively quickly a
95 maybe he should should have prevented
that the problem is that this might lead
to two structurally very bad positions
this is funny if you look at this the
computer here stockfish in this case is
giving h5 this black and this is this is
just a catastrophe continue the most
possible move
and white is winning because this is a
dead bishop the bishop will never ever
leave the the pawn chain iam it is just
incarcerated and i'm playing with 22
pieces against one piece on the
queenside this type of um configuration
computers still don't understand
properly that's amazing it gives white
only 0.1 and this is like gone
disposition died completely winning and
easily I mean I just play with the piece
up here maybe at some point he needs to
play you 5v5 and 36 or so but it's
completely over and this is the problem
of this position the other computer
suggestions are equally bad you must
take it it's the only move I guess now
here yeah and what this is just just a
bit better for white I have this this
pressure after some space advantage the
king is good in the center there are
some some things that add up here okay I
don't want to huh the computer was
straight i don't like that check and
maybe here there's some some room for
improvement even I played f4 which is
not bad but maybe there's still
something better computer wants to go
look h4 okay but really it's a position
where play I'm pretty confident about my
own judgment really it's not very
tactical and here yeah this was this was
okay I guess always keeping keeping an
edge due to the better King and space
here I found it's getting close to check
close to a quality somehow I mean yes
his reach term here some gained
something with the exchange don't still
still there are possibilities to to
probe computer wants to play f5 f5 f5 is
not so worse without its points the
problem is not that you don't want to
take you anything you want to play b5
that's not bad interesting idea i had
this a 4 idea this is strong and that is
strong maybe the check first is even
better maybe ya hear the computer wants
to play a 5 which looks really strange
but maybe check
yeah that's not so great that's a good
defense actually I didn't really
consider the move it always looks a bit
weird because of simple a5 and stuff but
he has rock edge 5v5 is nonsense Oh
computer gives this trying to go for
mating attack wow that's difficult to
play with little time yeah okay this is
this dangerous and I have chances to get
b7 and b6 um yeah it's always tricky for
black but certainly defensible okay this
is probably probably close to losing but
here maybe there's some something better
than what I played yeah but this is a
very good position and you probably
cannot expect more okay thanks for
watching it was a really interesting
game bye